what's going on everybody welcome to the
sixth TV basics tutorial video in this
video what we're gonna be talking about
is the float layout so this is another
version of a layout now as we can see
this layout is is fairly responsive you
know we can move things around at least
and the buttons are somewhat placed
decently but not the greatest and you
can do stuff like this right and and you
you can conceive there are some layouts
that are some reasons why you wouldn't
want this layout so I'm going to show
one more layout and that's going to be
the float layout so the idea of the
float layout is that you can kind of
dynamically size and place things so I
don't know stuff like this doesn't
really happen so anyway let's go ahead
and close this and talk about that so
for me I'm going to make some changes
again this will be my kv file for I'm
already regretting not keeping these the
same number as the video but that's okay
so case 6 and this one's already saved
as for cool so I'm gonna save that ok
now we're ready to go ahead and get
started so I'm going to the only thing I
would get rid of here let's see four
button will be size so we'll keep the
font size as 44 now I mean you might
want to change that something more
dynamic later on but we'll keep the font
size as 40 and we'll talk about the
other stuff later but then we'll just
delete this so currently we'll just have
a you know this button definition so
we'll save that and no longer do we need
our widgets class we're going to get rid
of that for now we want to keep
everything as simple as possible so you
can kind of see the required connections
and nothing more
so we're also going to get getting learn
to speak so here at a widget we don't
need that anymore and in fact we aren't
even going to need label we're just
going to have key v-app import app and
then one more thing we're going to now
say
from TV Dai UI x dot flow layout import
capital F float capital L layout now we
deleted our widgets class so we can't
use that anymore so we have to use float
layout so now our simple app is just
gonna return float layout now that's
really nothing it should run still but
there's really nothing to our float
layout it's just a blank screen at the
moment whoops
so I guess hold it here yes so how do we
add this float layout well all we need
to do is you know these parent and
children so now we can specify this
parent class that we have which is float
layout so let's just go ahead and do
that so add our little tags for the
parent and this is float layout
don't forget your colon it's really easy
for you Python folk 1 2 3 4 and now
we're ready to kind of define some
things about the float layout now for me
all I say that we're going to have two
buttons so we're gonna have a button
here and a button here now we can add
some text to our buttons so 1 2 3 4 and
we'll say text is a key B and then down
here or - oops
1 2 3 4 texts will be again TV so now
we've got two buttons with text we've
got font size and color but we don't
have the buttons sighs now one of the
kind of things about our float layout
that's going to be cool is that we can
use a dynamic size with some hinting and
we quite literally the parameter for
this is size underscore hint and we want
to say our size hint will say is point
four now we're going to say 0.3 I'll
show you I think the best thing is to
kind of write it out and then show you
how everything affects things but this
is basically 0.3 of the wit so in fact
let's do 0.25 so it's 1/4 of the X and
then of the Y we're going to say zero
point
oh I guess why actually let's do point
okay
we'll play with these later anyway um so
this is our button so now this is the
like the parent information so this
stuff is already being applied to these
okay the only thing that's different is
the text which I guess isn't different
some make this tutorials I don't know
why row TV twice
wasn't thinking I guess so we've got
text text and now the only other thing
that we really need to do is the
position of the button so for position
it's kind of like size hint and the term
here is going to be posts underscore
hence : and this is going to actually be
like a dictionary okay so you've got
your key and your value and the key can
be a lot of things you've got X Y
left/right up/down or top bottom press
I'm sorry X Y left right top bottom
sorry don't mean to confuse anyone so in
each one kind of has a slightly
different idea to it but anyway well
we'll use them all or will try to
anyways at least one from each of
dichotomy so we're going to say the X X
will be and actually this needs to be in
quotes so X : and we're going to say X
will be just 0 so this will be the 0
with or the no X okay so 0 basically
these values all of them are going to be
between 0 and they'll be somewhere
between 0 and 1 1 being full complete 0
being none so if x is 0 that should make
total sense to you where where is X 0
well it that means left all completely
left then now we need some sort of Y
definition now we could we could
literally say Y and we say Y is 0 or we
can say I think it's lower case T top
top but is top like top the question
it's like almost like a degree of tapas
so if we say top 0 this means it has 0
degrees of tapas so actually top 0 would
be bottom ok so we're going to say
one so this key B button needs to be or
will be according to the hints the top
left now that's not really that special
we could have done that really easily
but this button is where it's going to
really shine so now we will do a posts
underscore hint and again this time
we'll say instead of X we'll use a
different one we'll say right and this
is so our degree of rightness so if we
wanted a button to be completely right
what degree of rightness would we have
complete full rightness one then we'll
have another variable here and we'll say
for now I will just the top one again
and let's just make ups one and let's
make sure everything works up to this
point so we haven't really tested
anything right so now you've got key V
and you've got tutorials and then what
we can do is we can kind of move
everything around okay and you can see
that a couple of things are happening
not only are the buttons moving they're
changing in size so we could even
although the text is going to run over
but we could do this and you'll see that
the buttons themselves at least will not
run into each other so this would be an
example of having you know many
different screen resolutions yet
everything still fits and you've got no
run over so the float layout pretty much
can allow you to stop things from
running over each other so long as
you're using the hints right because we
can still make text run over well I'm
going to do it there we go okay you can
make text run over each other now um
that's basically it
but let's just really solidify what
we're what we're seeing here so let's
leave well now let's move TV so we're
going to say top whatever we'll say
instead of one zero point five so this
will be half topping this right so this
can get kind of confusing because now
when we say top is 0.5 it almost looks
like this keavy element right
like here's the top 0.5 is here and now
it's beginning to look like this element
here is being treated as if it's moving
around by the top-left corner right
because this marks 50% not this okay so
I can get pretty confusing pretty fast
or pretty challenging at least
especially because this so now this
application could in theory be almost
dictated by either the bottom left or
the top left that kind of sucks I could
get really confusing really fast but I
like the idea that you can orient things
by different different values but let's
try now Y 0.5 uh what I must have hit f5
on the TV okay let's drive over done
right so now and you can see how this is
by the Y element you know half and this
is illustrating how Y is indeed
referencing the bottom left because this
marks the halfway mark right down here
this of course doesn't we can see this
very easily visually so that's kind of
corresponding to the rest of keavy worst
top does it but then what if we said
okay we come over here and we said
bottom so the degree of bottom miss
there but 0.5 right okay so anyway you
can imagine that this can get pretty
confusing pretty fast especially like
you can you start playing with these
like say bottom is zero and then you're
expecting right like my expectation of
bottom equals zero would be actually top
right like it would be zero degrees of
bottomless but anyway I the reason why
that's occurring I believe anyways would
be is because the degree of bottom is to
zero but since everything starts at zero
zero
it remains at the bottom okay so I think
that's what's happening here and that
would be why maybe you would say why you
would I it's hard because it just
depends on which way you've always
you've been oriented
your program as far as like where you
want to you know what words you might
want to use but anyway keep it in mind
that it's going to be somewhat confusing
sometimes but you've got all of these
values and I think the best way to
envision these values is in Ness right
so this is X Ness - top Ness rightness
but you can do stuff like you know
degrees like this like right 0.3 for
example right let's do 0.5 for the one
that's over some and we can run that and
you can see here that it's always going
to start at about you know 30% so you
can move the window all you want and you
pretty much can always be comfortable as
far as where the button will be again
the text is not meshing with us but we
can work on that as well so anyway
that's going to be it for the float
layout and all that hopefully that made
sense
the first time I saw float layout and
really still I have to think about it
when I'm inputting these values because
you just first of all they've already
flipped you know where the zero zero is
on you and then you've got these degrees
of these values that you can input and
it gives you a lot of dynamic nests and
stuff like that but I can be confusing
so anyway but you can always pretty much
get away with using x and y but you
should probably know about these as well
anyways that's it for this tutorial I
have any questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support subscriptions until next
time